we have many
videos on the mean value theorem but i'm
going to i'm going to review it a little
bit so that we can see how this connects
the mean value theorem that we learned
in differential calculus how that
connects to what we learned about the
average value of a function using
definite integrals so the mean value
theorem
tells us that if i have some function f
that is continuous
continuous on the closed interval so
it's including the endpoints from a to b
and it is differentiable
it is differentiable so the derivative
is defined on the open interval from a
to b so not necessary it doesn't
necessarily have to be defined that
differentiable at the boundaries as long
as it's differentiable between the
boundaries then we know then we know
that there exists
there
exists
some value or some number i guess is
some number
some
number
c
such
that
c is between the two endpoints of our
interval so
let me such that a is less than c is
less than b so c is in this interval and
and and this is kind of the
the meat of it the meat of it is that
the derivative of the derivative of our
function at that point the derivative of
the function at that point you could
view it as the slope of the tangent line
at that point is equal to
essentially the average the average rate
of change over the interval or you could
even think about it as the slope between
the two endpoints so the the slope
between the two endpoints is going to be
your change in y which is going to be
your change in your function value so f
of b
minus f of a
over
over
b
minus a and once again we do this one we
go into much more depth in this when we
covered it the first time in
differential calculus but just to give
you a visualization of it because i
think it's always handy the mean value
theorem that we learned in differential
calculus just tells us that hey look you
know if this is a
this is b
i've got my function
doing
something interesting so this is f of a
this is f of b
so this quantity right over here where
you're taking the change in the value of
our function divided by so this right
over here is f of b
f of b minus f of a is this change in
the value of our function divided by the
change in our x-axis so it's our change
in y over change in x that gives us the
slope this right over here gives us the
slope of this line
this this the slope of the line that
connects
that connects these two points that's
this quantity and this the mean value
theorem tells us that there's some c in
between a and b where you're going to
have the same slope so it might be at
least one place so it might be right
over there where you have the exact same
slope there exist a c
where the slope of the tangent line at
that point is going to be the same so
this would be ac right over there we
actually might have a couple of c's
that's another candidate c there's at
least one c where the slope of the
tangent line is the same as the average
slope across the interval and once again
we have to assume that f is continuous
and f is differentiable now when you see
this it something might it might evoke
some similarities with what we saw when
we saw the the how we defined i guess
you could say or the formula for the
average value of a function remember
what we saw for the average value of a
function we said the average the average
value of a function is going to be equal
to one over b minus a notice one over b
minus a you have a b minus a in the
denominator here times the definite
integral from a to b
of f of x
dx
now this is interesting because here we
have a derivative
here we have an integral but maybe we
could connect these maybe we could
connect these two things
well one thing that might jump out at
you is maybe we could rewrite
maybe we could rewrite this numerator
right over here
in this form somehow and i encourage you
to pause the video and see if you can
and
i'll give you actually a quite huge hint
instead of being an f of x here what
happens if there's an f prime of x there
so i encourage you to try to do that
so once again this is let me rewrite all
of this this is going to be equal to
this over here is the exact same thing
as the definite integral from a to b
of f prime of x
dx think about it you're going to take
the anti-derivative of f prime of x
which is going to be f of x and you're
going to evaluate it at b f of b and
then from that you're going to subtract
it evaluated at a minus f of a these two
things are identical and then you can of
course divide by
divide by
b
minus a
now this is starting to get interesting
one way to think about it is there must
be a there must be a c
if we there must be a c that takes on
the average value of there must be a c
that when you when you evaluate the
derivative at c it takes on the average
value of the derivative or another way
to think about it another way to think
about it if we were to just write if we
were to just write let me say g of x
is equal to f prime of x
then we get very close to what we have
over here because this right over here
is going to be
g of c remember f prime of c is the same
thing as g of c
is equal to
1 over
is equal to 1 over b minus a
1 over b minus a so there exists a c
where g of c is equal to one over b
minus a times the definite integral from
a to b
of g of x
g of x dx f prime of x is the same thing
as g of x so another way of think
thinking about and this is actually
another form of the mean value theorem
it's called the mean value theorem for
integrals
mean value theorem for integrals let me
so this is the mean i'll just write the
acronym mean value theorem
for
for integrals or integration
which essentially and to give it a
slightly more formal sense is if you
have some function g
so if g
is let me actually
go down a little bit
which tells us that if g of x
is continuous
continuous
on
this closed interval
on going from a to b then there exists
then
there
exists
a c
in this interval where g of c is equal
to what is this this is the average
value of our function there is
exists a c
where
g of c
is equal to
the average value of your function over
the interval this was our definition of
the average value of a function so
anyway this is just another way of
saying you might see some the mean value
theorem of integrals and just to show
you that it's really closely tied it's
using different notation but it's
usually it's essentially the same exact
idea as the mean value theorem you
learned in when in differential calculus
but now a different notation and i guess
you could have a slightly different
interpretation when we're thinking about
it in in differential calculus we're
thinking about having a point where the
slope of the tangent line of the
function at that point is the same as
the average rate so that's when we had
our kind of differential mode and we
were kind of thinking thinking in terms
of slopes and slopes of tangent lines
and now when we're in integral mode
we're thinking much more in terms of
average value average value of the
function so there's some c where g of c
there's there's some c where the
function evaluated at that point is
equal to the average value so another
way of thinking about it
if i were to draw
if i were to draw
g of if i were to draw a g of x
if i were to draw
g of x so that's x that is my y axis
this is
the graph of y is equal to g of x which
of course was the same thing as f prime
of x but we've i guess we've just
rewritten it now to be more consistent
with our average value formula and we're
talking about the interval from a
to b
we've already seen how to calculate the
average value we've already seen how to
calculate the average value so maybe the
average value is
is that right over there so that is g
average so our average value is this the
mean value therefore integrals just
tells us there's some c where our
function must take on where our function
must take on that value at c whereas
that c is inside where the c is in that
interval